hey youtubers is charlie so yesterday
during my marvel video I asked you to
submit all your questions a lot of them
had to do with you know phase three
goings on female films so I'll try to
address all those here we go question
number one Catherine top tasks are there
any list you'd recommend for actually
getting into reading comics like x-men
Avengers guardians so you're basically
asking about all the big stuff so if you
don't use comiXology they basically just
got bought out by amazon so it's a
little bit different than what it used
to be but you can buy comics on your
desktop it has lots of starter lists and
huge discounts on like collected
editions especially guardians of the
galaxy right now just because the movies
out so I would recommend checking out
comixology they have just like a lot of
really easy collected editions on to
question number two Jack Pedley asks do
you think the Winter Soldier will make a
return in any of the new Marvel movies I
definitely think that Bucky is coming
back I still think of him as Bucky but
the filmmakers that made Winter Soldier
are also making Captain America 3
they're already working on it right now
they've talked about how it's gonna pick
up a couple years after the events of
winter soldier just because all the
Marvel films tend to line up in a linear
way like each film chronologically takes
place after the film that preceded it in
age of Ultron they're gonna explain why
Captain America isn't out looking for
Bucky because that's basically what he's
been trying to do he's gonna try and
help his friend Sebastian stand is still
under contract so he's going to continue
to play the winter soldier in future
Marvel films it's the same kind of deal
with Loki which all address in a later
point but you know secondary characters
like that tend to show up in the Canon
films like you might not see him in an
Avengers film unless he takes over the
captain america roll on to question
number 3 Steven Gonzales asks how many
Avengers movies do you think that
they'll make and when they stop what
other kinds of movies will they make so
they're absolutely never going to stop
making Avengers films they're way too
profitable they make way too much money
you may have noticed that they're not
calling avengers age of ultron avengers
2 they're calling it the second Avengers
film but technically the title is
avengers age of ultron they're doing
that subtitle thing where they don't use
the numbering scheme the reason they do
that is because psychologically at a
certain point you're like oh they're on
movie you know number for this is
getting kind of boring so by using
subtitles like age of Ultron they try to
get people to stop thinking about it
being the seventh or eighth
or 100th Avengers movie they do the
exact same thing in the comics whatever
they reboot new titles it'll be like
volume 1 volume 2 vol 3 but they're
really on like the hundredth or 500
issue of a comic what you'll also see
though is more team-based movies like in
humans is the next big team that they're
trying to develop defenders is also
going to be happening on Netflix but
that's going to be TV based actually I
take that back defenders is technically
on netflix so you can consider it a
miniseries but it's gonna be like film
quality question number four Jake Kane
asks do you think that we'll see
anything about fear itself zombies or
even alternate Avengers in movies
anytime soon so he has definitely
alternate Avengers coming in the next
you know like Avengers 3 you know post
Avengers 2 films but they're slowly
introducing new people into the roster
that they can cycle people out like
Quicksilver scholar at which they're the
new team members in age of Ultron as for
like the weirder stories no they're
probably going to do any zombie stories
any time soon typically like what
they're doing they're still pretty early
in development so they stick with like
the most basic stories and even those
get changed a lot like for instance
changing Ultron's backstory in making
Tony Stark as creator instead of Hank
Pym in the comics generally they try to
keep it as simple as possible and then
each director whenever he comes on a
project will just tweak things based on
the actors that he casts in what he
feels like the best story is going to be
so if they do fear itself you know
they'll just use sin like they'll use
red skulls daughter I'm actually really
hoping that those people red skull and
red skulls daughter sins show up in
Captain America 3 but that's not
confirmed we don't know anything about
that story question number 5 Andrew
widow masks do you think that Black
Widow Hawkeye or the hook will get their
own movies as it's been off from the
Avengers yes there definitely developing
more Avengers spin-offs i would think
that black widows probably going to be
the first one to get hers no
confirmation on that I know female
Marvel films is a hot topic right now
currently there are no plans for a solo
Hulk film like they're gonna wait
probably till phase four which is a long
ways off like after Avengers 3 Hawkeye
you know it's hard to tell Jeremy Renner
is a big part of the Bourne franchise
like he's going to be in the next Bourne
film and Hawkeye is not a super popular
character compared to the other Avengers
really what determines the spin-offs
like the order they do it is like a
board of directors will say you know
market data is telling us that people
will buy tickets to exfil
the reason Black Widow is going to be
one of those first female films whenever
that does finally arrived just because
Scarlett Johansson is a major a-list
actress things that have really high
public awareness always going to be much
easier for studios to green-light than
like new IP like we want a Captain
Marvel movie but the general public
isn't super familiar with who that is
but they absolutely totally know who
Black Widow is question number six cabs
plays asks is there any chance that the
post credit scene with Howard the Duck
might be wait to open up the defenders
to the MCU so I mentioned this in a
previous thing it doesn't have anything
to do with Howard the Duck but they
already planned a defenders team-up
movie for Netflix what's going to happen
is is all the Netflix series are going
to be like spin-offs for single
characters like Jessica Jones Luke Cage
daredevil right now they're actually
filming daredevil here's some pictures
of Matt Murdock from the set so once
they do each of those netflix series
then they'll do the defenders team up
there basically doing the avengers model
on netflix so they do the solo films
then they do the team up question number
7 mush p asks if robert downey jr's
character was killed off do you think
that they would go in the steps of the
comics and have James Rhodes become Iron
Man and CEO of Stark Industries so for
those that don't remember James Rose is
roadie he's war machine right now
essentially or iron Patriot however you
want to think about him this is actually
a really good question because I think
if Robert Downey jr. decides that he
does not want to renew a contract or he
and Marvel can't come to an arrangement
after Avengers 3 then what they'll do is
that just won't use the character
they'll send him off into space like
they did in the comics but I don't think
that they're going to kill him off what
you might see though is him being
replaced in the Avengers by vision but
the person that closest resembles the
Iron Man character another option would
be to replace him in the Avengers with
star-lord temporarily so if they got rid
of him there would be this massive power
vacuum so you'd have to have someone
capable of leading that giant team step
in so that either be captain america or
star-lord I mentioned star-lord just
because Chris Pratt now is like proven
to be a box office draw and in reality
that's what Robert Downey jr. is he's
like guaranteed box office dollars you
know Marvel needs a big a list hero that
can lead a team and right now Chris
Pratt is like the next best option
question number 8 dr Dinkins asks what's
going on with all the Marvel Netflix
shows are they
happening yeah they're also totally
happening they're just filming daredevil
right now they're filming them one at a
time they just found the cast for
daredevil so they're just not very far
along in production of those other TV
series but they are coming question
number 9 awesome bro asks which movie do
you want to hear confirmation on black
panther or in humans and why so this is
actually a good question they've already
confirmed black panther like it's in
development Kevin foggy like literally
in the last couple days said we
understand people really want this movie
we're developing it right now what he is
not confirmed is in humans like it's in
development but he hasn't publicly
stated yes we are making an Inhumans
movie so i'll say i'd like them to
confirm in humans because technically
they actually have confirmed black
panther they just haven't found a
director yet usually the way marvel
makes announcements about movies are is
they have you know hundreds of films and
characters in development once they find
something that they really want to make
they try to find a director once the
director signs on they make an
announcement it's just like the doctor
strange announcement that movie is being
made it has a director scott derrickson
it has a new writer but they don't have
an actor yet so you just haven't heard
anything about it in a while so they
make announcements as they hire people
question number 10 car gab asks what is
your favorite non Avenger Marvel
character I would actually say Luke
Skywalker because technically Star Wars
is now marvel like they're making Star
Wars comics at Marvel again I haven't
done any videos about the Star Wars
comics that Marvel is making but they
announced three of them at comic-con
it's going to be a lot of fun they even
have a princess leia specific comic
coming out so whenever those start being
released i'll probably do a couple
videos for them question number 11
million what are your expectations for
agents of shield season 2 so it's gonna
follow like the basic sequel formula
more comic book characters more complex
plots i talked a little bit about it in
my shield finale video from last season
so they're gonna use that black cube
that's going to give them their missions
like they're going to find some sort of
mysterious info or they're going to find
out about a villain and then go pursue
him and that'll be like their freak of
the week but like they just cast Lucy
Lawless and they just cast adrianne
palicki is mockingbird so they have all
these new comic book characters coming
in so I think it's going to be really
interesting and a lot of you are asking
to yes I'm planning on doing videos I
just haven't quite worked out what my
weekly video schedules
be once all these shows start airing I
might have to go a couple weeks without
sleep but I'll make announcements as
though show start airing because they
don't all start at the same time but you
can follow me on social their links for
that at the bottom the description like
Twitter and Facebook usually that's
where I disseminate that kind of
information question number 12 Grimlock
asks do you think that there will be a
female lead film announced soon and
which character would it focus on so
like I said Scarlett Johansson probably
gonna be first just because she's the
biggest alias actors that Marvel has on
contract right now whenever Kevin fike
he made that announcement about Black
Panther he was also talking about
Captain Marvel like they do have a
script in the works they just don't have
a director attached yet once they hire
director for Captain Marvel that's when
they'll make an announcement like you
know this movie is going to be released
at X date there was actually a lot of
backlash about them not announcing any
female films at comic-con and a number
of people pointed out that Kevin foggy
kind of talked around the idea about
when they were doing it technically he
is still beholden to a board of
directors so really if you're upset that
Marvel isn't making a female Marvel film
any time soon it's because you know like
the big big money people at Marvel
decided you know we're not ready for
that yet it doesn't really have anything
to do with whether or not Kevin
wants to make one because they all do
like everyone that works at Marvel would
love to see a female film question
number 13 David Rice asks what do you
think about the rumors Marvel is trying
to buy the film rights for spider-man
back from Sony this is actually
interesting topic so there are always
offers on the table like companies
always offer to buy other companies and
then it gets turned down and you just
never hear about it there's actually a
rumor right now the Disney has an offer
on the table to buy Time Warner Time
Warner owns Warner Brothers which owns
DC Comics so if Disney bought time
warner they would have the rights to all
the DC films as well as the Marvel films
as interesting is something like that
would be like that would be you know
creatively an amazing thing for Disney
to have access to all that IP the FCC
has to approve it though if they say you
know no we feel like this is a monopoly
even if they wanted to pay a trillion
dollars for Time Warner they still
wouldn't be able to do it there's
actually a Chinese company that's also
in talks to buy time one or two so that
actually might change hands so you might
see different people owning all the DC
characters in reality I don't see Sony
giving up the rights to spider-man like
they're trying to create their own
franchise universe like their own
version of the Marvel Universe in terms
of financial success Sony's doing
right now so anything they have that is
a guaranteed moneymaker they're not
going to let go of question number 14
Andrew Wong asks how do you think
they'll introduce Peter Cole's father in
the guardians of the galaxy sequel so
I'll actually start by saying what I
hope they do not do so I'm hoping that
it's not like a deus ex machinist
situation whereby you know Peter quill
in the Guardians get into a really big
bind and somebody swoops in like Adam
warlock is his father and he swoops in
and saves him at the last minute they're
definitely gonna play out the mystery of
his father and he will appear in the
sequel James Gunn's already said yes
we're gonna be doing Peter Cole's father
or exploring that history in greater
detail but I'm not expecting it to be
like a really clear explanation like Man
of Steel you know where by a Superman
pushes a button and his father comes up
and goes hello I'm your father I really
do hope it's Adam warlock though just
because that character has been used
with Thanos so much in the comics like
he's an integral part of the fano
stories question number 15 JB bluray
asks what are your thoughts on a thor
ragnarok movie so supposedly serdar was
rumored to be the villain for thor the
dark world until they change things in
malkit than dedup being the villain
what's going to happen though is is
they're gonna have to get Thor back into
space or back to Asgard that is during
age of Ultron supposedly he's going to
have bit living on earth since the end
of dark world I know that sounds weird
but think about it this way at the end
of dark world he essentially told what
he thought was his father who was really
low key that he didn't want to be king
so he came back to earth to live with
Jane so Thor 3 will probably explain
what's been happening in Asgard since
then like what's been happening while
Thor's been away this whole time clearly
things probably won't be going so well
so Thor will have to fix as garden and
question number 16 last one Kourtney and
Lindsay asks do you think that we'll see
Loki in other movies besides Thor 3 i'm
really hoping that he shows up in the
third avengers movie supposedly he's not
going to be in avengers age of ultron
tom hiddleston does still have a couple
movies left on his contract so even if
he does Thor 3 which she totally will
he'll have more movies besides that so
I'm hoping that he's involved in
whatever the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
is and Avengers 3 there's actually a big
rumor that they're going to do that
Harry Potter thing where they split
Avengers 3 into two different movies
that's not confirmed at all but I think
it'd be interesting just because it
given the opportunity to you know allow
Thanos to get the Infinity Gauntlet in
the first
movie and then spend the second movie
with the Avengers trying to fix things
like fix the universe I know that sounds
totally crazy but this is so far off
that we have no idea how things are
going to change but I think it's an
interesting idea so thank you so much
for so many questions there's a lot of
fun I'm also working on an arrow season
three villains video for later today
I'll try to get that out tonight you
know hopefully by like 10 or 11pm but be
sure to subscribe to get that and let me
know if you want me to do more Marvel q
days because I do really like doing
these videos because there's a lot of
talk about the second guardians movie
the sequel I might do a video for Adam
warlock next week but also don't forget
doctor who is this weekend I know I've
been telling everybody in like every
single video I do but it is going to be
so awesome and I'm so looking forward to
it saturday Saturday night doctor who
remember so just because I've been
talking about Doctor Strange so much
recently click here to learn about my
top five doctor strange stories that I
hope that the movie does especially now
since there's been rumors that they're
not going to do an origin story and
click here to learn what I think the
stories are going to be four Guardians
to thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys tonight high fives
you